The Hidden Brain Team has felt a range of emotions as we've watched the spread of coronavirus. Like you, we've had moments of frustration and anxiety and fear. Such emotions can play a big role in our response to a disease outbreak. Another key factor are ability to trust the guidance of public health experts. We forced to explore this idea several years ago while working on an episode about an Ebola outbreak in Africa. We thought we'd bring you that story today in the hopes that it may remind us that expertise combined with authentic human connection can achieve a lot during times of uncertainty.
在见证冠状病毒蔓延的过程中，Hidden Brain 团队百感交集。和你们一样，我们也有过沮丧、焦虑和恐惧的时刻。这种情绪在应对疾病爆发时会起到很大的作用。另一个关键因素是我们是否有能力信任公共卫生专家的指导。几年前，我们在制作一期关于非洲埃博拉疫情的节目时，被迫探讨了这一想法。今天，我们想把这个故事带给大家，希望它能提醒我们，专业知识与真实的人性联系相结合，在充满不确定性的时期可以取得巨大成效。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. In 1950, before he directed the film on the waterfront, Elia Kazan made another dramatic thriller, a movie called Panic in the Streets. There's a reason you probably haven't heard of it. It isn't a great movie. Here with recorded is the story of a silent savage menace, the events, incidents and emotions of the people who were a part of it, who found time running out as they looked into the face of mortal peril. The film tells the fictional story of a murder in New Orleans.
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆 (Shankar Vedantam)。1950 年，在执导电影《码头风云》之前，伊利亚·卡赞 (Elia Kazan) 拍摄了另一部惊悚剧情片，一部名为《危机四伏》(Panic in the Streets) 的电影。你可能没听说过这部电影是有原因的。它并不是一部伟大的电影。这里记录的是一个沉默、野蛮的威胁的故事，是身处其中的人们所经历的事件、事故和情感，他们在面对致命危险时发现时间正一点点流逝。这部电影讲述了一个发生在纽奥良的虚构谋杀案。
When the police investigate, they find the victim suffered from a deadly infectious disease, a version of the plague. Public health officials believe the killers may have contracted the disease as they carried the victim's body away. What follows is a race to track down the criminals and halt an epidemic, a collision of law enforcement and public health. If the killer is incubating you money, plague, you can start spreading it within 48 hours. 48 hours? Yes, we have 48 story where life imitates art.
当警方展开调查时，他们发现死者患有一种致命的传染病，一种瘟疫的变种。公共卫生官员认为，凶手在搬运受害者尸体时可能感染了这种疾病。随之而来的是一场追捕罪犯和阻止疫情爆发的竞赛，这是一场执法部门与公共卫生部门的碰撞。如果凶手身上潜伏着瘟疫，你可以在 48 小时内开始传播它。48 小时？是的，我们有 48 小时的故事，在这里生活模仿了艺术。
It's a story about disease and panic, but it's also a story about psychology. To control an epidemic takes more than medical skill. It requires an understanding of human behavior and the forces that drive people to act in certain ways. Our story starts in Munrovia, the capital of Liberia. A deadly crisis was sparking fear, news reports were filled with dramatic language and catastrophic warnings. The Ebola virus is back to an Ebola breakout in West Africa. This quote totally out of control. A catastrophe is unfolding.
这是一个关于疾病和恐慌的故事，但它也是一个关于心理学的故事。控制一场流行病需要的不仅仅是医疗技能。它需要对人类行为以及驱使人们做出某种行为的力量有深刻的理解。我们的故事从利比里亚首都蒙罗维亚开始。一场致命的危机正在引发恐惧，新闻报道中充满了戏剧性的语言和灾难性的警告。埃博拉病毒卷土重来，西非爆发了埃博拉疫情。这句话完全失控了。一场灾难正在上演。
The world's deadliest outbreak of Ebola. Highly infectious, quick to kill with no vaccine and no cure. The Ebola outbreak reached its peak in the fall of 2014. By the end of the year, it was subsiding. But then in early 2015, in a poor part of Mondrovia, there was a new outbreak, or cluster. And it led to the complex case we're focusing on today. I got a call from someone who said, if your passport isn't in my office in the next two
世界上最致命的埃博拉疫情。高度传染性，杀戮迅速，没有疫苗，也没有治愈方法。埃博拉疫情在 2014 年秋季达到顶峰。到年底时，它正在消退。但随后在 2015 年初，在蒙罗维亚的一个贫困地区，爆发了新的疫情或聚集性病例。它引出了我们今天关注的复杂案件。我接到一个电话，对方说，如果你的护照在接下来的两个
hours, you won't make your flight to Liberia. Ethelia Christie is an epidemiologist with a Centers for Disease Control and Prevention or CDC. She flew to Mondrovia to help track and stop the outbreak. Lots of CDC officials joined her, like Frank Mahoney. People were scared. It was a crisis. You could drive through the city and see people that were being left out on the street,
小时内没送到我的办公室，你就赶不上飞往利比里亚的航班了。埃塞莉娅·克里斯蒂 (Ethelia Christie) 是美国疾病控制与预防中心（即 CDC）的一名流行病学家。她飞往蒙罗维亚以帮助追踪和阻止疫情爆发。许多疾控中心官员和她一起前往，比如弗兰克·马霍尼 (Frank Mahoney)。人们很害怕。这是一场危机。你可以开车穿过这座城市，看到人们被留在街上，
you know, for people to come pick them up. Frank and Athelia told me how the case we're following today started. Police in Mondrovia discovered a body in a warehouse. A young man dead with multiple stab wounds. Police were called in. A swab was taken as mandated by the official policy that any dead body be swabbed.
你知道的，等着人们来接他们。弗兰克和埃塞莉娅向我讲述了我们今天所关注的这个案件是如何开始的。蒙罗维亚警方在仓库里发现了一具尸体。一名年轻男子死亡，身上有多处刀伤。警方被叫到了现场。根据官方政策（即任何死尸都必须进行拭子采样），警方提取了拭子。
So even though the police who arrived there initially thought they were investigating a murder, they did follow the procedures and have the body swabbed at which point we were alerted because the test came back positive. Positive for Ebola. Once police identified the youth, they quickly realized they had a major problem on their hands. It turned out the young man was actually part of a large street gang. Yeah, it was like a gang. One of them, for whatever reason, he got stabbed by other members of the group.
因此，尽管最初到达那里的警察认为他们在调查谋杀案，但他们确实遵循了程序并对尸体进行了拭子采样，就在那时我们得到了警报，因为测试结果呈阳性。埃博拉病毒呈阳性。一旦警方确认了这名年轻人的身份，他们很快意识到自己遇到了一个大麻烦。原来这个年轻人实际上是一个大型街头帮派的成员。是的，就像一个帮派。不知什么原因，他被该团伙的其他成员捅了。
As we understand it, there was a knife fight, and we're not quite sure how it happened but the friends turned on him. Just a review, a young man contracts Ebola, he gets in a fight and it's stabbed repeatedly by fellow members of his gang. Ebola remember is highly contagious, come into contact with an infected person sweat or blood and you could fall sick too. The gang had as many as 35 members. Each had connections far and wide across the city. And just like in that movie, Panic in the Streets, public health officials needed to quickly stop the outbreak from spreading.
据我们了解，当时发生了一场持刀斗殴，我们不太清楚它是怎么发生的，但朋友们背叛了他。回顾一下，一个年轻人感染了埃博拉病毒，他卷入了一场争斗，并被他的帮派成员多次刺伤。记住，埃博拉病毒具有高度传染性，接触感染者的汗液或血液，你也会生病。该帮派多达 35 名成员。每个人都在这座城市的四面八方有着各种联系。就像那部电影《危机四伏》中一样，公共卫生官员需要迅速阻止疫情蔓延。
They needed to try and find every person who could have come into contact with a young man. It's a process called contact tracing. It's exceedingly difficult to do if you tried to imagine constructing the last three weeks of your life and determining every single person that you came into contact with, whether it was casual contact or a family member who you saw every day, it's extraordinarily difficult to do. So we interview people multiple times, and we also talk to their family members and their friends
他们需要尝试找到所有可能与这名年轻人有过接触的人。这是一个被称为接触者追踪的过程。如果你试着想象构建你过去三周的生活，并确定你接触过的每一个人，无论是泛泛之交还是你每天都能看到的家庭成员，这都极其困难，这是极其难以做到的。所以我们多次采访人们，我们还与他们的家人和朋友交谈
to try to determine everyone who might have had any contact with this person during the time that they could have been infectious. Aetherian Frank knew the young man who died had sought medical treatment for his tab wounds. Had a healthcare worker sutured the young man's wounds and come into contact with his blood? Ethelia visited a lot of clinics trying to track down facilities the young man may have visited. She paged through logbooks of patient names with no luck. Then she got to one clinic. And I took this big dusty logbook and I opened it up and literally the page I opened it to, there's maybe 30 names to a page and I read down them and there he was at the bottom
以试图确定在此人可能具有传染性的这段时间里，所有可能与此人有过任何接触的人。埃塞莉娅和弗兰克知道，死去的年轻人曾因刀伤寻求过医疗救护。是否有医护人员缝合了年轻人的伤口并接触了他的血液？埃塞莉娅走访了许多诊所，试图追踪年轻人可能去过的医疗机构。她翻阅着患者姓名的日志，但一无所获。然后她来到了一家诊所。我拿起这本厚厚的、布满灰尘的日志，把它翻开，字面意思是我翻开的那一页，一页大概有 30 个名字，我向下读去，他在第一页的
of the first page. A healthcare worker at this clinic had sutured the young man's knife wounds. Ethelia knew what she had to do. The most difficult part of these investigations come when you need to tell the clinicians and all of the staff who work in these healthcare facilities that someone with Ebola entered the facility. And I remember how nervous the individual was when I told him that the person he, he sutured, had been
底部。这家诊所的一名医护人员缝合了这名年轻人的刀伤。埃塞莉娅知道她该做什么。这些调查中最困难的部分是，当你需要告诉这些医疗机构的工作人员和所有员工，曾有埃博拉患者进入该机构时。我记得当我告诉那个人他缝合过的人当时
positive for Ebola at the time. It's hard to imagine what he was going through. Can you recall what you told him and what he said? We were standing in the hallway and I told him that there's no easy way to tell anybody this. And so we just told him very matter of factly, and that we needed to maintain daily contact and monitoring with him coming in for treatment the moment that you have symptoms. And the reason I remember this so clearly is that he didn't do that. He was very reluctant to go to an Ebola treatment unit. The healthcare worker refused to be quarantined. He insisted he'd followed all safety procedures
埃博拉病毒呈阳性时，他是多么紧张。很难想象他当时经历了什么。你还记得你对他说过什么，他又对你说了什么吗？我们站在走廊里，我告诉他，没有什么简单的方法可以把这件事告诉任何人。所以我们只是非常客观地告诉了他，并且我们需要对其实施日常接触和监测，一旦他出现症状，就要前来接受治疗。我之所以能把这件事记得这么清楚，是因为他根本没有这么做。他非常不愿意去埃博拉治疗中心。这名医护人员拒绝被隔离。他坚称自己在包扎年轻人伤口时遵循了所有安全程序
as he bandaged the young man's wounds. He told Atheria he'd get in touch if he started to have any symptoms. Atheria knew there was a reason the healthcare worker had refused to come into an Ebola treatment unit. It had to do with a lack of trust in the system. In fact, the more Ethelian Frank saw, the more they realized that Ebola wasn't the only enemy they were fighting in Mondrovia. They were dealing with an epidemic of mistrust. After a long history of civil war and corruption, a lot of people in Liberia simply didn't
他告诉埃塞莉娅，如果他开始出现任何症状，他会联系她。埃塞莉娅知道这名医护人员拒绝进入埃博拉治疗中心是有原因的。这与对系统缺乏信任有关。事实上，埃塞莉娅和弗兰克看到的越多，他们就越意识到埃博拉并不是他们在蒙罗维亚与之战斗的唯一敌人。他们正在应对一场不信任的流行病。经过长期的内战和腐败，利比里亚的许多人根本不
trust the government or international organizations. When Ebola broke out, the government's first response was to try and control it using coercion. Coordinating off sections of towns, it created panic. The government had attempted involuntary quarantine and they had a really bad experience in the slums of Manrovia. And so we talked about, you know, is this a viable strategy? We all agreed, no, we can't use involuntary quarantine. This is not something that's going to build trust in the community. It's not a way to manage the outbreak. People also worry that if they did go into quarantine, they would never come out. Ethelia pointed to the construction of one of the largest Ebola treatment units in Liberia.
信任政府或国际组织。埃博拉爆发时，政府的第一反应是试图通过强制手段来控制它。封锁部分城镇，这造成了恐慌。政府曾试图进行非自愿隔离，他们在蒙罗维亚的贫民窟里有过非常糟糕的经历。所以我们讨论过，你知道的，这是一种可行的策略吗？我们一致认为，不行，我们不能使用非自愿隔离。这不是能在社区中建立信任的事情。这不是管理疫情的方法。人们还担心，如果他们真的被隔离，就永远不会出来了。埃塞莉娅指着利比里亚最大的埃博拉治疗中心之一的建设。
And it was chaotic and difficult and they built it all and they forgot to put an accident. They didn't build an exit because we weren't thinking about survivors at that time. And although this was many months later, many people understandably so thought that going to an Ebola treatment unit meant that you would not come home. Dealing with mistrust, the public health officials knew was central as they began to trace all the leads of this complex case.
而且过程混乱且艰难，他们把一切都建好了，却忘记留一个出口。他们没有建出口，因为我们当时没有考虑幸存者。尽管这是几个月后，但许多人理所当然地认为，去埃博拉治疗中心意味着你将无法回家。公共卫生官员知道，应对不信任情绪是他们开始追踪这一复杂案件所有线索的核心所在。
As a failure had been tracking down the healthcare worker, Frank had been pursuing a different strand of the investigation, tracking down the members of the young man's gang. This was a community that was not on the best terms with the government. You know, they were very suspicious of the government. So it really is a trust building exercise to go into this community to piece together all these pieces of the story.
正当埃塞莉娅一直在追踪这名医护人员时，弗兰克一直在进行调查的另一个方向，即追踪这名年轻人帮派的成员。这是一个与政府关系不太融洽的社区。你知道的，他们对政府非常怀疑。所以进入这个社区拼凑出所有这些故事，确实是一个建立信任的过程。
Very quickly, Frank and Athelia realized they were in over their heads. They needed help. So when we did the investigation, I went with this librarian. Fantastic librarian epidemiologist. Ersa name Musaka Fala. Musaka Fala. I'm Musaka P. Fala. As a librarian, Musaka Fala understood things far better than the Americans. He also understood the horrors of Ebola, first hand, the disease had killed his sister. Musoka's first order of business was to help track down the young men in the gang. Surprisingly, they weren't hard to find, but they were scared. Scared that the police, who were still investigating the case as a homicide,
弗兰克和埃塞莉娅很快意识到他们力不从心。他们需要帮助。所以当我们进行调查时，我和这位利比里亚人一起去了。出色的利比里亚流行病学家。他的名字叫穆萨卡·法拉 (Musaka Fala)。穆萨卡·法拉。我是穆萨卡·P·法拉。作为一名图书管理员，穆萨卡·法拉对事物的理解远比美国人好。他也第一手了解埃博拉恐怖之处，这种疾病杀害了他的妹妹。穆萨卡的首要任务是帮助追踪帮派中的年轻人。令人惊讶的是，他们并不难找，但他们很害怕。害怕警方（仍在将此案作为凶杀案进行调查）
would arrest them for their role in the knife fight. The police wanted to go in. However, if we allow the police to go in, they can still be escaped and we have pretty close to 35 young men, who were all hard-wrapped contact on the loose. This is similar to what happened in Panic in the loose. This is similar to what happened in panic in the streets. Musoka says Frank sat down with the police. He told them that any investigation of the murder would send gang members into hiding and potentially spread Ebola further. This will allow the Ebola team to go in and negotiate so that we can have the contact and the police agreed and the police withdrew their arrest and that's how we went into negotiate.
会因为他们在持刀斗殴中所扮演的角色而逮捕他们。警察想进去。然而，如果我们允许警察进去，他们还是会逃跑，我们有将近 35 名年轻人在逃，他们都是高度危险的接触者。这类似于发生在……这类似于发生在危机四伏中的事情。穆萨卡说弗兰克和警察坐下来谈了谈。他告诉他们，对谋杀案的任何调查都会迫使帮派成员躲藏起来，并有可能进一步传播埃博拉病毒。这将允许埃博拉团队进入并进行谈判，以便我们能够进行接触，警察同意了，警察撤回了他们的逮捕令，这就是我们进入谈判的方式。
And this everyone told us is what allowed public health officials to start talking to the young men in the gang. So, to recap, public health officials had tracked down the health care worker who treated the young man and identified all the people they could tell the young man had come into contact with. The epidemiologists quickly found themselves staring at a growing web. There were three important strands. First, the young men in the gang would have to be persuaded to enter an Ebola quarantine
每个人都告诉我们，正是这一点让公共卫生官员开始与帮派中的年轻人交谈。因此，总而言之，公共卫生官员已经追踪到了治疗这名年轻人的医护人员，并确定了他们所能知道的曾与这名年轻人有过接触的所有人。流行病学家很快发现自己正盯着一张不断扩大的网。这里有三个重要的线索。首先，必须说服帮派中的年轻人进入埃博拉隔离
facility for 21 days. Second, there was a woman running the drug house who was connected to the gang. Gang members were in and out of her home all the time. Most worries them, the public health officials heard the woman was sick, and they thought that she might have Ebola. She had a hard career for two days and she was getting sick. Finally, there was one member of the gang they could not track down. During the fight, this man had held down the stabbing victim as the blades came out and the blood splattered. And now, Frank and others found he'd run away.
设施呆上 21 天。其次，有一个女人在经营着与该帮派有关联的毒窝。帮派成员经常出入她的家。最令人担忧的是，公共卫生官员听说这个女人病了，他们认为她可能感染了埃博拉病毒。她咳嗽了两天，而且病情越来越重。最后，有一个帮派成员他们无法追踪。在打斗过程中，当刀子拔出、鲜血四溅时，这个人按住了被刺伤的受害者。现在，弗兰克和其他人发现他已经逃跑了。
Oh, what was his name? His name ironically was Timebomb. Coming up, how to stop the outbreak and find Timebomb. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. We're exploring how, in early 2015, epidemiologists tried to stop Ebola from spreading in a poor slum in Liberia. They had three fires to put out. Time bomb had gone underground. The rest of the
哦，他叫什么名字？讽刺的是，他的名字叫定时炸弹 (Timebomb)。接下来，如何阻止疫情爆发并找到定时炸弹。请继续收听。这里是 Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们正在探讨在 2015 年初，流行病学家如何试图阻止埃博拉病毒在利比里亚的一个贫民窟中蔓延。他们有三场火要灭。定时炸弹已经潜伏起来了。其余的
gang had been identified, but were reluctant to be quarantined. And then there was the woman known as drug mama. She was the godmother of a drug den frequented by members of the gang. She was in her thirties and appeared to have symptoms that suggested Ebola. If Ebola struck the heart of the drug den, it would spread very quickly through the community. Frank and Musoka realized they had to quickly run a test to get drug mama diagnosed, but they anticipated problems. Our dilemma was how do we approach such that she accepts us to do an Ebola test? The mere mention of Ebola was sending people into a panic. If they told her they were worried she had Ebola, would she vanish and go underground?
帮派成员已被识别，但很不情愿被隔离。然后是被称为毒品妈妈 (Drug Mama) 的女人。她是帮派成员经常光顾的毒品窝点的教母。她三十多岁，似乎有暗示埃博拉的症状。如果埃博拉袭击了毒窝的核心，它将通过社区迅速蔓延。弗兰克和穆萨卡意识到他们必须迅速进行检测以确诊毒品妈妈，但他们预计会有问题。我们的困境是，我们该如何接触，才能让她接受埃博拉检测？仅仅提到埃博拉就会让人陷入恐慌。如果他们告诉她他们担心她得了埃博拉，她会消失并潜伏起来吗？
They didn't want to take the chance. So rather than take her into confidence, they decided to trick drug mama. It wasn't ideal, but they were dealing with the crisis. They had to improvise. So Frank being the smart guy he is, we stopped at a pharmacy and we bought her malira medicine. And when that night in Frank said, ah, you're not so well. So we brought you some medicine. This is around 9 p.m.
他们不想冒险。因此，与其取得她的信任，他们决定欺骗毒品妈妈。这并不理想，但他们正在应对危机。他们不得不即兴发挥。因此，弗兰克发挥他聪明的本色，我们在药店停下来，给她买了一些疟疾药物。那天晚上弗兰克说，啊，你身体不太好。所以我们给你带来了一些药。这大约在晚上 9 点。
She said, yes. So Frank said, take this medicine. I will come back tomorrow and check on you. And so the goal was the next morning, we asked for her blood to go check if she had malira and then we'll run the Ebola test. The trick worked up to a point.
她说，是的。于是弗兰克说，吃下这药。我明天回来看看你。所以我们的目标是第二天早上，我们要求抽血去检查她是否有疟疾，然后我们再进行埃博拉检测。这个把戏在某种程度上成功了。
The problem was the next morning when they took Drug Mama to the hospital to get her blood drawn, they had to tell healthcare workers at the hospital what was going on so everyone would take proper precautions. A nurse got scared when they told her they wanted to test for Ebola. Drug Mama noticed the nurse acting oddly. And then she suspected something else. The drug Mama left and went back home and became angry with us. Musoka and Frank realized the trickery was backfiring. So they tried bribery.
问题是第二天早上，当他们把毒品妈妈带到医院抽血时，他们不得不把情况告诉医院的医护人员，以便每个人都采取适当的预防措施。当护士听到他们想要检测埃博拉时，她吓坏了。毒品妈妈注意到护士表现得很奇怪。然后她怀疑有别的什么事。毒品妈妈离开了，回到了家，并对我们感到愤怒。穆萨卡和弗兰克意识到这种诡计正在适得其反。于是他们尝试行贿。
We sat down with her, we negotiated and we told her we gave her $100 US if she allowed us to do a blood draw at a house. So we took the blood and at 7pm that night we got a response that she was negative and we all went to bed, breathing a sigh of release. Frank and Musoka turned their focus to the second strand in the web, the young men in the gang. Patiently, they explained to the young men that they would be safe from police harassment in the Ebola treatment unit. We worked it out with them. We worked out an arrangement where they, if they agreed to come into the isolation facility,
我们和她坐下来，我们进行了谈判，我们告诉她，如果她允许我们在家里抽血，我们就给她 100 美元。于是我们抽了血，那天晚上 7 点，我们得到了她呈阴性的回复，我们都松了一口气，上床睡觉了。弗兰克和穆萨卡将他们的注意力转向了网中的第二条线索，即帮派中的年轻人。他们耐心地向年轻人解释，在埃博拉治疗中心，他们将免受警察的骚扰。我们和他们解决了这个问题。我们达成了一项协议，如果他们同意进入隔离设施，
you know, the CDC, I think we ended up paying their families some support costs because they were no longer able to earn money for their families and the government provided the families with food. And so it worked out really well. But even this was not enough. It turned out some of the young men were drug addicts. Frank realized he had to keep asking the government to bend the rules in the Ebola treatment unit or E.T.U. I told the government that we had to anticipate that some of these young men may be drug users and they may go into a thrall if we put them in the E.T.U.
你知道的，疾控中心，我想我们最终向他们的家人支付了一些生活补贴，因为他们不再能为家庭赚钱，政府为这些家庭提供了食物。所以这一切进展得很顺利。但即使这样还不够。事实证明，一些年轻人是瘾君子。弗兰克意识到他必须不断要求政府在埃博拉治疗中心（E.T.U.）放宽规则。我告诉政府，我们必须预料到这些年轻人中有些可能是吸毒者，如果我们把他们送进 E.T.U.，他们可能会陷入戒断状态。
And in fact that was the case, about two to three days later, they were some of them getting the E.T.U. and in fact that was the case about two to three days later. They were some of them getting agitated and somehow they found a way to support their their needs for drugs. Did you have to do some of that to help them get what they needed to keep them in this facility where they could be quarantine? No, I didn't, the CDC succeeded in paying for that or do that, but the government found a way for the communities to support them. So they were doing that. But in some ways, it's sort of an awkward situation for the government because in some ways,
事实确实如此，大约两到三天后，他们中的一些人进入了 E.T.U.，事实确实如此，大约两到三天后。他们中的一些人变得烦躁不安，不知怎的，他们找到了支持自己毒品需求的方法。你是否不得不这样做来帮助他们获得他们需要的东西，以将他们留在可以隔离他们的设施中？不，我没有，疾控中心成功地为此付了钱或者这么做了，但政府找到了让社区支持他们的方法. 所以他们在这么做。但在某些方面，这对于政府来说是一种尴尬的局面，因为在某些方面，
you're asking the government to sort of look the other way while someone's doing something illegal here. Yeah, I think that they, but at the same time, they'd be like any withdrawal. They needed treatment. It wasn't a conventional treatment, that's for sure. It was odd for public health officials to be sanctioning illegal drug use. But again, when you're in the middle of an unfolding catastrophe, you sometimes have to bend the rules.
你是在要求政府睁一只眼闭一只眼，而有人在这里做违法的事情。是的，我认为他们，但与此同时，他们就像任何戒断反应一样。他们需要治疗。这肯定不是常规治疗。公共卫生官员批准非法吸毒是奇怪的。但话说回来，当你身处一场正在展开的灾难之中时，有时你必须打破规则。
Even though CDC wasn't actually supplying anyone drugs, the arrangement produced lots of double takes. One day a Liberian government minister turned to Frank during a discussion and joked about the backdoor drug channel. And he says, and I understand that CDC is providing them with the marijuana. And I said, excuse me sir, I said, I'd like to correct that. He said CDC is not providing the marijuana, but we're providing the copain.
尽管疾控中心实际上并没有向任何人提供毒品，但这一安排还是引起了许多异样的目光。一天，利比里亚政府的一位部长在一次讨论中转向弗兰克，开玩笑地谈到了后门毒品渠道。他说，据我所知，疾控中心正在向他们提供大麻。我说，不好意思，先生，我说，我想纠正一下。他说，疾控中心没有提供大麻，但我们提供可卡因。
I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said,
我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，
I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said,
我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，
I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I said, I actually managed to quarantine the gang members. These were young men who no one thought would listen to the authorities. But by reposing trust in them and treating the young men as partners, the public health officials had found a solution that seemed to work better than coercion or trickery. Still, this wasn't the end. There was a third strand of the web they had to track down. Time bomb. Time bomb became very elusive. We could not find time bomb. At first, gang members did not want to tell Musoka or Frank where time bomb was.
我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我说，我设法隔离了帮派成员。这些是没有人认为会听从当局安排的年轻人。但通过重新信任这些年轻人并将其视为合作伙伴，公共卫生官员找到了一个似乎比强制或欺骗更有效的解决方案。尽管如此，这并不是终点。他们还有网上的第三条线索需要追踪。定时炸弹。定时炸弹变得非常难以捉摸。我们找不到定时炸弹。起初，帮派成员不想告诉穆萨卡或弗兰克定时炸弹在哪里。
But as we built friendship and rapport with the other criminals, one of them took us to his house. There, they found a young man, a young woman and a baby. The epidemiologist asked the young man if he was time bomb. He said, I'm not time bomb. Time bomb is going out. I'm his younger brother. But if he comes back, I will let you know.
但随着我们与其他罪犯建立友谊和融洽关系，其中一人带我们去了他的家里。在那里，他们找到了一个年轻男子、一个年轻女子和一个婴儿。流行病学家问这个年轻人他是不是定时炸弹。他说，我不是定时炸弹。定时炸弹外出了。我是他弟弟。但他如果回来，我会让你知道的。
Then I said, OK, thank you very much. It was at this point that Musoko and Frank did something very kind and very wise that led to a breakthrough in the case. He had a young baby. And I remember giving the wife a hundred dollars and said, go ahead and buy milk for the baby, feed the baby, and we'll take care of you. Something changed in the young man's demeanor. After I did that, he turned to me and said to me, I am Tom Boom. Frank and Musoka told Time-Bomb and his wife
然后我说，好的，非常感谢。正是在这个时候，穆索科和弗兰克做了一件非常善良且非常明智的事情，从而取得了案件的突破。他有一个年幼的婴儿。我记得给了他妻子一百美元，并说，去吧，给孩子买牛奶，喂养孩子，我们会照顾你们的。年轻人的态度发生了变化。在我这么做之后，他转向我对我说，我就是定时炸弹。弗兰克和穆萨卡告诉定时炸弹和他的妻子
that they would be back that night. They promised they would return with more food. Frank came to me with the food and said, Musoka, we need to go to meet this guy. This was in the ghetto. I went with Musoka and it was like 10 o'clock at night. There was no electricity. This place was pitch black.
他们那天晚上会回来。他们承诺会带着更多食物回来。弗兰克带着食物来找我，并说，穆萨卡，我们需要去见这个人。这在贫民窟里。我和穆萨卡一起去了，当时大约是晚上 10 点。没有电。这个地方漆黑一片。
We had to go and drive to the grass. This was like a slum community, it's known to have gangsters. And that's why the friend was emphasizing that we had to keep our word. We had to trust us. This was the key. So we brought food to him and his family. I think a couple of sex to rise in things.
我们不得不开车驶入草地。这就像一个贫民窟社区，以黑帮闻名。这就是为什么这位朋友强调我们必须信守诺言。我们必须信任我们。这是关键。所以我们给他和他的家人带来了食物。我想有几袋大米之类的东西。
As we walked towards them and the saw us come to a rise on our pseudo, for some reason it trusted us and it came to the car and help us take the rise. Frank and Musoka gently asked time bomb whether he was willing to come to the Ebola treatment facility to be quarantined. Time bomb said he wasn't ready to do that. Frank and Musoka said they understood, but they were willing to trust him to do the right thing. If you get sick, you call us and he said I will do that, I trust you guys. And so I think it was a matter of building a trust and comfort level for him to talk to us.
当我们走向他们，他们看到我们带着大米来到我们的车前时，出于某种原因，它信任我们，并来到车前帮助我们搬大米。弗兰克和穆萨卡温和地询问定时炸弹是否愿意去埃博拉治疗中心接受隔离。定时炸弹说他还没准备好这样做。弗兰克和穆萨卡表示他们理解，但他们愿意相信他会做正确的事。如果你生病了，给我们打电话，他说我会的，我相信你们。所以我觉得这是一个为他建立信任和舒适度，以便与我们交谈的问题。
In the end, none of the young gang members contracted Ebola, not even time bomb. The cluster did not spread in the ghetto. Drogmama recovered from her illness. Only one person connected with the cluster was affected. The medical worker who'd sutured up the young man's wounds, the one that went into hiding after a failure talked to him, he came down with Ebola-related symptoms. Eventually, he did see treatment, but it was too late.
最后，年轻的帮派成员中没有人感染埃博拉病毒，甚至连定时炸弹也没有。聚集性疫情没有在贫民窟蔓延。毒品妈妈从疾病中康复了。只有一名与此聚集性病例相关的人受到了影响。缝合了年轻人伤口的医务人员，也就是在埃塞莉娅找他谈话后躲藏起来的那个人，出现了埃博拉相关症状。最终，他确实去寻医了，但为时已晚。
He died, unfortunately, in the Ebola treatment unit. We started today's episode with a 1950 movie Panic in the Streets. At the end of that movie, the hero, a public health worker, ends up in a warehouse with the criminals who are carrying the deadly plague. He pleads for them to hand over their guns. But they get into a climactic shootout and the criminals are killed. The public health workers in Liberia never saw things with guns. And really, when it came down to it, Ethelia says,
不幸的是，他在埃博拉治疗中心去世了。我们以 1950 年的电影《危机四伏》开始了今天的节目。在那部电影的结尾，英雄——一名公共卫生工作者，与携带着致命瘟疫的罪犯一起落入了仓库中。他恳求他们交出枪支。但他们陷入了激烈的枪战中，罪犯被击毙了。利比里亚的公共卫生官员从不带着枪看待事情。真的，归根结底，埃塞莉娅说，
they achieved some of their best results without coercion or trickery. Building those invisible but very real bonds of trust took time, but it was essential to stopping an outbreak. When it comes down to what we were asking people to do, either to trust the healthcare system or to trust, the government enough to agree to this voluntary precautionary isolation. That's an extraordinarily difficult thing to do.
他们在没有强制或欺骗的情况下取得了最好的结果。建立那些隐形但非常真实的信任纽带需要时间，但这对于阻止疫情爆发至关重要。当归结为我们要求人们做的事情时，无论是信任医疗系统，还是信任政府到足以同意这种自愿预防性隔离。这是一件极其困难的事情。
You're asking people to leave their friends and family for 21 days or we were asking people to change their burial customs. And it's difficult. It can sound simple and I know that I spoke to people here who would say, I don't understand why can't they just change the way they bury the dead or change the way they care for their family members if they're sick. But as a mother, I can't imagine not touching my child if he was sick and not trying to provide comfort. So it's really understanding what it is that's driving people. You have to understand their context, their concerns, and their needs. I think it's about interpersonal relationships.
你是在要求人们离开他们的朋友和家人 21 天，或者我们是在要求人们改变他们的丧葬习俗。这很难。这听起来很简单，我知道我在这里与人们交谈过，他们会说，我不明白为什么他们不能仅仅改变埋葬死者的方式，或者如果他们的家人生病了，为什么不能改变照顾他们的方式。但作为一名母亲，我无法想象如果我的孩子生病了却不去触摸他，不试图去安慰他。所以这真的是要理解驱动人们的动机。你必须了解他们的背景、他们的担忧和他们的需求。我认为这是关于人际关系。
You have to be honest and straightforward about what you need and why. And most importantly, I think you need to be human. This week's show was produced by Chris Benderer and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Path Shah, Reya Cohen, Laura Correll, Thomas Liu, Kat Chuknecht and Lu Sheikwaba. We had original music from Ramteen Arableui. Our An Sang Heroes this week are Beth Donovan and Rolando Arieda. Beth oversees NPR's LifeKit podcast and Rolando is the deputy director of NPR's new operations. They've taken the lead in developing plans to keep NPR's journalism and podcast coming
你必须诚实、直率地说明你需要什么以及为什么需要。最重要的是，我认为你需要有人情味。本周的节目由克里斯·本德尔 (Chris Benderer) 制作，塔拉·博伊尔 (Tara Boyle) 和珍妮·施密特 (Jenny Schmidt) 编辑。我们的团队包括帕特·沙阿 (Path Shah)、雷亚·科恩 (Reya Cohen)、劳拉·科雷尔 (Laura Correll)、托马斯·刘 (Thomas Liu)、卡特·舒克内希特 (Kat Chuknecht) 和卢·谢库瓦巴 (Lu Sheikwaba)。我们的原创音乐来自拉姆蒂恩·阿拉布鲁伊 (Ramteen Arableui)。我们本周的无名英雄是贝丝·多诺万 (Beth Donovan) 和罗兰多·阿里达 (Rolando Arieda)。贝丝负责 NPR 的 LifeKit 播客，罗兰多是 NPR 新闻运营的副主任。他们带头制定计划，以确保 NPR 的新闻和播客源源不断地
to you, even if we can't make it to our usual studios during the coronavirus outbreak. We're really grateful to both of them. For more hidden brain, you can connect with us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please share it with one friend. I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
向你传送，即使我们在冠状病毒爆发期间无法去我们通常的录音室。我们非常感谢他们两人的付出。想了解更多 Hidden Brain 的内容，你可以在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上与我们联系。如果你喜欢这期节目，请把它分享给一位朋友。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是 NPR。你 本集节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。